[Musique]
bonjour valérie boyer merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on dirait que ce matin
sur rtl france alors on a vu beaucoup de
réactions hier sur la lenteur de la
vaccination en france
certains députés les républicains
craignent une pénurie quel est votre
sentiment
je voudrais surtout qu'on ait une
information qui soit à la fois fiable et
j'avais dire honnête vis-à-vis des
français aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a besoin de savoir
combien de médecins de quel type de
vaccin on a besoin aussi d'avoir quelque
chose de clair sur la conditionnalité
des vaccins est ce que on va faire comme
pour nos enfants vous savez que nos
enfants s'ils ne sont pas vaccinées
peuvent pas aller à l'école publique
pour certaines maladies particulièrement
contagieuse et qui ont été éradiqués
d'ailleurs de quasiment en tout cas de
nos pays
donc toutes ces questions là il faut
concéder cause de façon honnête et pas
qu'on avance en promettant tout et son
contraire je vais vous citer un exemple
aujourd'hui ça ne choque personne quand
on veut
il ya quelques années avant d'imaginer
qu'on soit dans la peau ninon dans cette
pandémie
ça ne choque personne imaginez qu on se
vaccine contre la fièvre jaune pour
aller dans certaines zones y compris de
france moi je pense par exemple à la
guyane ça ne choque personne quand une
compagnie australienne me demande si on
est à jour si on a fait un test
stipulant qu on n'a pas de grands
navires us pour prendre aussi ligne
n'ont donc toutes ces questions là elles
doivent être réglées de façon claire et
nette par le gouvernement qui doit
prendre des décisions et non pas qui
ressort des citoyens pour l'éclairer oui
alors effectivement au lit les verront
hier a donné des indications il dit que
plus de 5000 vaccination avait été
réalisée hier soir à 17 heures on va
regarder justement son tweet au ministre
de la santé et on en parle après à 17
heures plus de 5000 vaccination et été
réalisée aujourd'hui en france dans une
trentaine d'hôpitaux
demain c'est une centaine d'hôpitaux qui
auront été livrés
en dose merci à toutes les équipes
mobilisées alors on a l'impression
effectivement que le gouvernement donne
et mesure au fur et à mesure en tout cas
de son rétropédalage amplifié et
accéléré simplifié c'est le nouveau mot
d'ordre du gouvernement après le fameux
tester isolé tracé écoutez le moods on
si c'était pas si triste ce serait
vraiment amusant quand on voit toutes
les mesures qui ont été mises en place
pour pour simplifier entre guillemets
alors qu'il ya cinquante mille comité
théodule
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure et qu'on a en plus eu recours à
des citoyens tirés au sort ce qui est
quand même la négation de démocratie la
négation de la compétence la négation de
la décision pour la stratégie vaccinale
aujourd'hui le gouvernement peut-être de
se gargariser des dents d'être à 5 me de
vaccination alors que nos pays les pays
voisins sont soit des millions de
vaccinations donc pour la voilà en tout
cas bastien tu as fait je pense qu'on
arrivera à ce chiffre là donc on peut
pas on ne comprend toujours pas ce qui
se passe et c'est vrai que la confiance
est très fortement altérée à la fois sur
la stratégie vaccinale mais aussi sur
sur le vaccin lui même et sur la façon
dont on doit utiliser le vaccin
pourtant la france est un des pays au
monde qui a la meilleure couverture
médicale avec des personnes compétentes
je vais vous citer un seul exemple le
réseau des pharmacies vous savez qu'il
ya une pharmacie pour 2500 habitants en
france et que les pharmaciens voici
millions de personnes par jour moi je ne
comprends toujours pas comment on
n'utilise pas un outil qui est
extraordinaire qui est celui de la carte
vitale
tous les sites au toutes les personnes
qui sont en france ont une carte vitale
à partir de 16 ans qu'elles soient en
situation régulière ou irrégulière pour
pouvoir et pour pouvoir comment dire
avancer sur la stratégie vaccinale par
exemple pour voir quelles sont les
personnes qui sont immunisés aujourd'hui
ça veut dire depuis combien de 13 ans
fait un test négatif
celles qui ont eu le celles qui ont eu
le coronavirus depuis par exemple jeudi
à des mois qui serait déterminé par les
autorités médicales et celles qui sont à
risque pour commencer à avoir une
stratégie claire
des vaccins aujourd'hui tout ça n'est
pas fait moi ça me laisse absolument
[Musique]
j'allais dire stupéfaite de tous les
autres tic et bien on ne les utilise pas
aujourd'hui et communiqué une brouille
entre voire arrogante de la part du
ministre de la santé
au-delà de la polémique sur une
éventuelle pénurie est ce que ce n'est
pas finalement le trop-plein de
précaution qui a fait que le
gouvernement s'est tiré une balle dans
le pied
je pense que le trop plein de précaution
malheureusement il existe dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres où on
préfère avoir des regrets plutôt que des
remords si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
hamon en donner un moment donné il faut
que le président de la république soit
un président de la république qui est
qu'ils cessent d'être dans la
communication qui cesse d'être en
campagne permanente et qui les
gouvernent
quand pour une question aussi
stratégique aussi importante qui
paralyse la planète entière parce que
c'est la première fois je crois que
l'histoire de l'humanité qu'ont
partagent tous la même difficulté à
n'importe quel endroit de la planète où
n'importe quel régime etc
quand sur ces questions là on passe par
dessus le parlement on passe par dessus
les corps constitués on passe par les
compétences demandées en tirant au sort
à 35 personnes d'évaluer la stratégie
vaccinale
je pense que là on est dans la négation
de ce qui fait même la république
française il est basé quand même sur qui
est basé quand même qui est basée sur
l'égalité la fraternité aussi la liberté
qu'elle est je veux dire quelle est la
valeur ajoutée de tirage au sort
comment on fait un déni totalement la
compétence médicale l'autorité qui est
lié à la compétence et j'allais dire ça
ça donne une image absolument tron caire
et des lettons quais et des de ce que
peut apporter la science est
l'organisateur non à une stratégie
vaccinale ce 35e au sort ça veut dire
qu'on préfère des gens qui n'ont aucune
compétence sur ce sujet plutôt que des
gens qui ont une compétence
que ça fait presque un an que nous
sommes paralysés par cette épidémie
jean castex a dit hier pas de polémiques
stériles écoutez le la polémique je le
dis à tous n'est absolument personne et
n'apportent aucune solution n'est ni sur
le terrain sanitaire ni sur le terrain
économique et social
nous sommes tout à fait déterminés pour
protéger et vacciner les français
tout se fera on a un chemin que nous
traçons et que nous suivons alors
affiché une détermination et c'est bien
est-ce que la polémique n'a pas fait
avancer les choses au contraire je suis
consterné de ces propos du ministre du
premier ministre que je respecte bien
évidemment mais comment on en sait un
problème de polémiques en est là parce
que on constate chacun du bon sens
chacun d'expérience moi je suis
parlementaire donc bien évidemment je
vais assister je l'espère à l'audition
du ministre de la santé pour savoir ce
qu'il a à nous dire là-dessus c'est pas
un problème de polémique c'est un
problème pour le parlement de contrôle
parce qu'il est dans sa mission de
contrôle c'est aussi un problème de
décision pour le parlement parce que
nous sommes aussi là pour décider
et puis c'est un problème aussi de deux
gouvernements de gouvernance de la part
des membres du gouvernement qui se
contredisent matin midi et soir sur tous
les plateaux avec un président de la
république qui dit elle a son propre
gouvernement ça suffit maintenant vous
n'allez pas assez vite vous n'êtes pas
bon donc nous sommes en démocratie le
président de la république était le
chantre d'un nouveau monde qui allait
changer avec plus de proximité plus de
rapidité etc
après avoir usé le grand débat pour
passer par dessus la tête tous les camps
ont situé et soi-disant se rapprocher
des aigus maintenant il est face aux
français aussi avec un gouvernement qui
le dit en tout cas qu'il ne soutient pas
et même qu'il méprise en le temps sans
vertement à la télévision donc récemment
il a fait une intervention en disant
qu'il n'allait pas assez vite et que c
est ce qui se passait pour les vaccins
étaient totalement
vin n'était pas à la hauteur des
attentes des français pour faire sobre
donc aujourd'hui je suis triste de voir
alors que le premier ministre considère
que des réactions des demandes
d'informations sont une polémique ce
n'est pas une polémique est celui qui
polémique au sein du gouvernement c'est
le présent la république remercie
beaucoup valérie boyer d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct à vos questions sur
rt france